part of the problem that we have here is
we keep indulging Russia and Putin the
people around him in their narratives of
[Music]
History so thank you very much for
coming to the interview here today um so
starting quite General um why do you
think many people in the west have sort
of misunderstood Putin and his his uh
way of thinking about the world I think
there are many reasons for that honestly
and part of it now is that he's been
there for so long that he's almost
become kind of part of the scenery for
people which might sound a bit absurd
but I mean think he's been in office for
23 years and at the beginning it was a
mystery and people still kind of think
to themselves there's a bit of
mysterious uh attributes there that they
probably don't understand but I mean 23
years in plain sight I mean we actually
know quite a lot about him but I think
that you know one of the fundamental
reasons is that at the top level of
governments in the United Kingdom in the
United States and across Europe people
change all the time so in a way we keep
losing the plot at least politically so
know the average person like you know
you and I and others who were interested
in Russia might have been following
Putin you know for 20 odd years and know
quite a lot about him I mean I written a
book about him so yeah I've been
following quite a long time but people
in government come and go and you know
in a way they keep kind of losing the
thread and they keep coming back and
reinterpreting him and he himself is
something of a deliberate political ion
you know he kind of changes his
appearances in a way and his whole
attitudes to sort of suit the person
that he's meeting with I mean this is
deliberate because of course he was in
the KGB in the security services it's
his job to dissemble it's his job to
manipulate people to exploit their
vulnerabilities and you know he often
you know presents himself differently
now I think over the last few years what
people have perhaps not realized is that
I don't know whether he's changed
dramatically but he's evolved and
hardened because after 20 three years in
power power of course will corrupt power
of course will change you you know he
he's lost a lot of the pragmatism that
he might have had early on and he
started to think of himself as the
indispensable figure in Russian history
and he's going to shortly be one of the
longest serving Russian leaders
historically you know with the exception
of people like Stalin yeah and you know
some of uh some of the Zars and he's
kind of moved into this phase of being a
legend in his own lifetime of being a
historical figure and he thinks about
himself in that way and I think that's
probably the thing that people have
misunderstood the most is that he's kind
of morphed into this um
self-referential historical figure he
has started to think of himself in these
historical terms and it's kind of warped
his sense of reality he's very much cut
off in ways that you he probably wasn't
in the past from you know even the
country and the people uh that he's
purporting to rule over and I say rule
over because he starts to think of
himself now as a zar as a kind of modern
incarnation of some of his historical
heroes like Peter the Great and even
Catherine the Great I think the
historical parallel and this historical
reflection is very important there so
how do you think that this this notion
of Putin as someone who's placing
himself amongst the greats of Russian
history amongst the um the kind of
Imperial rulers of old if we if we were
to keep that in mind or if we Western
European leaders were to keep that in
mind when engaging with him in
geopolitical negotiation and so you know
what practically would that look like
for them how how would one respond
differently to him say than various
leaders of the western world have
already well look I mean we're all
looking at the moment after the invasion
of Ukraine for some kind of solution
here which looks like practical
pragmatic uh on you know the basis that
there must be some rational basis of
compromise the problem is that Putin is
living in a different historical
narrative from everyone else yeah and in
a way we're battling for history which
of course is possible yeah because
everybody has their own narratives of
History um there are some you know
pretty basic objective facts but there's
always these different interpretations
of history and history looks very
different from everyone's perspective
and we were sitting on in in hey on why
on the border between England and Wales
and British hist looks very different if
you're Welsh and it looks very different
if you're English you know so I'm
thinking about that in the Russian
Empire on a vast scale and Putin is
always reinterpreting the past and on
his terms and in fact he's even outlawed
different interpretations of different
historical periods for Russia including
World War II right so that makes it very
difficult find a common ground and a
basic understanding for negotiations and
I think actually we have to push back
against these narratives because in many
respects we in the west and elsewhere in
the world have fed this war by taking
Putin's historical narratives at face
value let me just say you know a word or
two about this you know first of all
Russia remains an Empire Imperial State
it's still includes within its borders
uh areas that were absorbed over
centuries of
expansion and you know we failed to
recognize that when you had the collapse
of the Soviet Union or the dissolution
of the Soviet Union in 1991 that was
really the second iteration of the
Russian Empire because uh the Bolsheviks
uh basically had to recognize that some
uh territories like Finland and Poland
and the Baltic states uh had got their
independence uh from from Russia After
the Revolution and the Civil War but
under the Soviet period fast forwarding
to Stalin Stalin took a lot of this
territory back again he's Rees the
Baltic states we never recognize them
are being Incorporated he T to take
Finland back and the fins fought back in
1939 but they lost a bunch of territory
and of course then after World War II
Poland Hungary and a whole host of other
um Eastern European countries had never
been part of uh the Russian Empire uh
fell under the Soviet block yeah and so
um in Russia um today having been
recognized as the successor state of the
Soviet Union people like Putin the
cohort of people around him who grew up
in the Soviet Union who was steeped in
Russian history tend to think that
Russia has a right of to have a sphere
of influence and a right of authority
over all of these other states either
those that were formerly part of the
Russian Empire and those that were in
the Soviet block after World War II and
people indulge that we still say well
the United States or the West is at
fault for expanding NATO because we
moved into Russia's sphere of influence
and I would say hang on a second do we
really think in the 21st century that
countries should still have sever of
influence the United States shouldn't
have one I mean there's a view in the
Russian State uh not just Putin's but
widely shared that the United States is
still an occupying force in Europe and
it's still the Imperial force in Europe
from their Viewpoint yeah now of course
Europeans would think very differently
the United Kingdom obviously doesn't see
that the United States as sort of the
Imperial power um in Europe and you know
the United Kingdom has had its own
throws of imperialism and post
imperialism and all kinds of problems
like the sez crisis 1956 you know for
example so Most states have been trying
to move on move away from uh the
Imperial age move away from uh you know
colonialism but Russia is actually still
persisting in this and because we
recognized Russia was the successor
state to the Soviet Union and then
essentially the Russian Empire we have
given Russia this kind of right to make
these expansive claims and that is you
know part of our problem here and again
you know people are always saying well
of course Ukraine was part of of Russia
well it wasn't you know for large
periods of History you know Wales was
somewhat independent you know up until
you know various centuries of English
expansion there's there's always a
history in a different historical period
to look at and so I said you know part
of the problem that we have here is we
keep indulging Russia and Putin the
people around him in their narratives of
History so be able to get to a
negotiating table get to some kind of
resolution we have to in a way
demilitarize this history we have to
push back against it because we have to
move forward if we keep going back into
history and making claims against other
countries and other peoples and other
regions I mean there really is no end to
this I mean I grew up in northern
England where you know the Roman Empire
was so should we go back to Rome I mean
they certainly predate you know a lot of
other English History the Romans were
there first you know kind of thing if
you if you start playing this out you
know so so we have to as actually say
look no this is not going to work we
cannot have any kind of negotiation
resolution here that is basically
satisfying one group's view of History
so this leads to quite an interesting
question about how current events are
interpreted as part of a history as part
of a historical narrative so one of the
interesting comparisons that's been made
between Putin and Donald Trump was um
this idea that um how the facts actually
were was like less relevant than how the
presentation was was going to come
across right to the extent that some
people um would mention frankfurt's idea
of and and say you know this is
a a new era of politics an era of
politics in which you know you can just
fly in the face of facts but I think
maybe a more subtle interpretation comes
from that understanding that actually
it's not just some random inter
interation is it it's an interpretation
that's come from a line of History A
Narrative of History where the present
fits into that narrative and what you
think of the historical narrative is
going to dictate how you take the event
of today or yesterday that's right um
and so if we're going to try and come to
the negotiation table and we're going to
as you say have to bring up the fact
that one Narrative of History has been
running the negotiations how do we we
successfully changed that I mean what
what what can we say to really bring out
the question that there are other
narratives that in fact you know
Imperial Russia isn't the only narrative
in Europe well how as a practical matter
how how do we do it's going to be very
difficult I mean look on on the way up
to the war there were actually all kinds
of different commissions including you
know the Russians having them with the
poles and the Germans and others you
know to talk about you know their
various differences and all the
historical baggage I mean whether we
like it or not we can't be a historical
because we live with the way history it
shapes us I mean just as human beings we
shaped by that we have a lot of great
things going on here at hey and why
about how attitudes are shaped there's
lot research now they even showing you
know your DNA which is of course is the
genetic history that we have going back
to our forbears really kind of shapes
sometimes even your attitudes kind of
things that you're interested in which
would seem kind of counterintuitive but
we can't just SLO all of this off right
and and the um important thing is to try
to establish some kind of Baseline at
least agreement that we're not going to
be dictated by pe different groups
interpretations of history and finding a
way forward now it's going to be
obviously very hard but I think that has
to be a debate on a much larger scale
and you know in in many respects it's
going to be very hard for countries like
the United States and the UK because we
have an awful lot of baggage but there
are you know other countries with
different kind of histories that could
play a role in here and could push you
know forward to the negotiating table
you can see for example that zilinsky
himself uh president zinsky of Ukraine
that is has picked up on this you know
he's been traveling around all over the
players talking to different uh
countries with different interpretations
of History different perspectives here
and basically saying what Ukraine is
trying to do is fight for its
independence for ukrainians rights to
just talk about their own future and
have their own future not be dragged
back into somebody's past because what
Putin is trying to do is drag Ukraine
back into Russia's past and making the
past dictate the present and then shape
the future and you know that was the
whole uh premise of previous politics
that we tried to cast off after World
War II I mean I've made the argument in
different formats that this is going to
you know in a way World War I in a
structural sense because it's kind of
fighting again for the territorial
disposition of uh Europe as we did in
World War I and World War II and
people's rights to Define themselves as
they want to be defined I'm not trying
to get into identity and culture wars
here but people wanting to you know
basically have their own governance and
their own um you know statehood
self-determination you know however we
want to you know basically call that but
the right for people to determine their
own future not have somebody dictate it
for them I mean this is all of the Deb
that we're having in society at the
moment so we have to find a way of
finding a political Baseline here and I
think that that involves more parties
being brought to the table with all
kinds of different perspectives and we
just have to you know resist that idea
that because ukrainians speak Russian or
lots of ukrainians have spoken Russian
they are Russian that determinism you
know if we go into Wales and people are
speaking English but identify themselves
as Welsh why are they not Welsh you
don't have to be just uh a Welsh speaker
to be Welsh you your roots may go back a
long time but you know your family uh
have become dominantly English speaking
if everyone in the world who spoke
English was English it would be a very
different planet that we'd all be living
on you know so I think that's you know
kind of part of we have to speak out
about this and we have to make common
cause with a larger you know kind of
group of countries and peoples you know
who want to emphasize sovereignty
territorial integrity and the ability of
people to move forward into a future
that they're shaping not being you know
dragged back into a past that's then
determining where they can go I mean I
think the the mention of bringing in
other parties is really crucial here
right because so the kind of narratives
that are at stake and the kind of
narratives that are influencing today's
negotiations today's politics are postc
World War
European sort of and including America
narratives um and even even some of the
virtues which I think we still generally
Hold Us important things like you know
um National sovereignty
self-determination the ability to talk
about your own future in your own past
as a country um even those are quite
postc World War kind of values well post
uh treat West failure exactly I mean we
we're again prisoners of of the past to
some degree you're saying yeah and and
so but there are obviously lots of other
nations who who you know weren't at the
forming of NATO who weren't at the
formation of these large International
bodies that even yeah including the UN
that play big roles in politics today
and I mean some of those countries have
decided that um you know non-alignment
is the best way for them to interact
with this issue this the the invasion of
Ukraine and the more General issue about
how Russia sees itself in Europe how are
we I mean should we be bringing them to
the table to to this discussion of
history and current that how that
affects current events I mean how do we
interact with people who've decided look
this is is you know we're not aligning I
I think we should in terms of trying to
find a a way out of this absolute
disaster right because you know whether
you know they want to be part of it or
not uh the war in Ukraine and they
certainly don't want to take sides you
know we can list off all the kind of
countries heck of a lot of them who fall
into that category they are affected by
it yeah I think everybody now is aware
of Ukraine's incredible role in terms of
feeding the world literally and you know
if you look at the potential crop from
Ukraine in this coming year because of
what's actually happened as a result of
the war itself and destruction of a you
know sizable percentage of Ukraine's um
arable land and we're not just talking
about the Black Sea uh grain blockade
for exports of grain that uh you know
the Russians have imposed but we're
actually looking at what's happened to
you know Ukraine's uh land and then
potential crop yields between 10 and 20
million people could die because of this
because other parts of the world if they
have a crop failure you know they can't
substitute and I said between 10 and 20
so that means that you know no matter
what we're going to have deaths from
famine hunger uh you know malnutrition
you know you name it basically because
of uh Ukraine being kind of taken out of
the picture to a large extent so we need
to get you know Ukraine back on board as
a major agricultural producer and
exporter for the rest of the world
there's all the other knock on effects
through sanctions and everything else
that's happened that's you know
affecting food prices inflation you know
we saw all of that obviously in the
earlier parts of the world with winter
and fuel prices spiking
some of this is kind of evening out now
but it has affected other countries and
will affect some of them acutely so
there is here an incentive and an
interest in getting involved in
somewhere to find a resolution but we
have to then find a resolution that
doesn't set a negative precedent and
that's where this comes in for other
countries that again don't want to be
alive they certainly don't want to take
sides they don't want to get caught in a
kind of a clash between the US and China
for example or the US and Russia and
which is another reason for why it
shouldn't be just driven by the us or
for by Europe but you know they want to
make sure that their own territorial
integrity and Independence is not
compromised by this and you're
absolutely right they didn't feel like
the international institutions have been
working for them although there is a
great deal of interest in beefing up the
UN General Assembly and its various
mechanisms that's where the UN grain
dealers come out to you know try to get
the world food program and other
institutions getting grain out to the
places that it's needed but there is an
interest in trying to find you know a
resolution that sets a healthy precedent
for the future and reduces the that
other countries that are vulnerable to
larger neighbors especially those that
might be nuclear powers are not going to
be compromised in somewhere by this but
so that's the tricky thing so what are
the mechanisms and you know I've
obviously been thinking about this as
well if we see the UN grain deal that
was an important in a role that the UN
could play there are other mechanisms
for example the Russians have been
absolutely devastating in their approach
to civilian nuclear power not just
threatening nuclear armor again with
tactical intermediate r nuclear weapons
but actually holding nuclear power
stations hostage and shelling them going
through the Chernobyl exclusion Zone
zapara the largest nuclear plant in
Europe every day being at uh being held
at risk by Russian military activity and
we've seen the UN intervene there as
well the international atomic energy
agency you know we've seen the
international court of justice and the
international criminal court and others
play different roles but a lot of
countries supportive of those kinds of
roles of the UN because they want to see
more attention to their
concerns as well and if that could come
out of the war with Ukraine more
attention to climate change Regional and
you know Economic Development debt
relief mechanisms that would protect you
know them from predation military and
political then I think you know
countries would sign up for some kind of
effort but if it's again going to be the
great powers like in World War I and
World War II just sitting about in you
know various places behind conference
tables signing away you know the future
of Europe or you know the world future
that's not what most countries want to
see and you seeing that reflect at the
elite level and also at the popular
level so we've got to think long and
hard about how you bring in countries
that would otherwise not want to be
aligned in particular blocks that's
fascinating thank you so obviously
you've been privy to some of the
characters that we see on the news
you've spoken to world leaders you've
you you've seen how these people think
sometimes firsthand um yeah what what
are some of the most valuable lessons
that you've personally gained from those
interactions
well I mean sometimes they're very
cautionary TS because you know you
really kind of see the limits um many of
our leaders you know today I mean I've
seen some pretty inspirational you know
people as well at firsthand but you know
there's only so much one individual can
do and I think you know the biggest
risks that we have in today's politics
is the personalization of politics right
and we see the strongman phenomenon you
know on every Frontier I mean lots of
books being you know written about this
you know for example and it's it's a
feature of our time time because you
know when you have a time of Rapid
change people really can't keep up and
they're kind of looking for some
mechanism say stop the world I want to
get off or stop the world I don't want
it to change anymore and it's very easy
for individuals to um uh come forward in
that regard and present themselves as
Champions you know the populist leader
but you know they're very limited and so
I mean the things that I've learned the
most is just this importance of having
checks and balances in system and also
to be honest the the power of people
power I mean we've we've all got
ourselves to you know be instead of
follow was be more uh active um and you
know think about actions that we can
take and you know what are the best
leaders are those who actually listen to
other people and really take their
advice on board but we also have to
again understand the limitations of the
political systems that we're in people
are always blaming you know the US for
this or you know the UK for that and you
know our systems themselves are quite
Limited in the information that gets
brought forward I mean it's
extraordinary important to try to find
you know again mechanisms of openness so
that information comes in because you're
only as good as the things that you know
and you know the advice that you can uh
you can take on board and you know and
I've again I've learned you know how
important it is to have good analysis to
have objective analysis you know to
basically bring that forward so to help
people uh make decisions but there is
also then you know the importance of
speaking out when things take you know
pretty a pretty negative turn yeah but
you know this is a moment where all of
our politics you know kind of across the
world are really jeopardized by this
kind of idea that strong men populist
politicians can really resolve things
and really really what we we do need is
more kind of Grassroots action and
figuring out other ways of giving people
you know Stakes uh stakes in the system
and I mean i' I've taken all that away
from you know being on the inside and
seeing really the limitations right but
I've also seen you know how much things
can be done by small numbers of
dedicated people you know have a shared
sense of mission and responsibility so I
would also you know kind of um make an
appeal for you know thinking more
positively about public service and
Civil Service of you know all kinds of
uh a different uh different levels
because again you know governance is
only as good as the people who get
involved in it brilliant well F thank
you very
[Music]
much